haha the Joe Rogan experience I used to
be known about the catch line Oh it'll
be done when it's done you know when
when will doom ship when it's done when
will quake ship when it's done and it
felt good saying that in terms of that
was sort of the being rebellious about
we don't have any publisher that's gonna
force us to be out in time for their
quarterly earnings we're going to make
sure we we ship the game when it's
actually done but the aspects of seeing
I with a little bit more perspective now
it's like if you're talking slipping a
quarter slipping six months yeah great
that's definitely fine but when you're
talking about slipping years you know
when years go by the world changes
around you in a way that being a kind of
totalitarian about it'll only ship when
it's done I largely recant from that now
we're with a little bit more perspective
time has a physicality that you may not
appreciate and I have the two big reads
on that I am seeing some of like Virgin
Galactic they're never gonna make that
money back they're looking into
satellite launch for things now but even
the the last big game that I worked on
it in which was rage I'm we spent six
years on that game and we went into that
I am it was using flashy new technology
which there's some other life lessons
about that I but we had like we had an
e3 where we were game of show at e3 but
you know we kept on it didn't quite ship
and by the time it got out the world had
changed around us you know the
technology decisions that were made for
some earlier systems weren't necessarily
the right thing for the the very latest
ones we now had Call of Duty and
Battlefield coming out as these jogger
knots that we were competing with and I
look back as one of those real decisions
I think we should have done whatever it
would have taken to ship that two years
earlier be less ambitious with some of
the technologies and get it out earlier
and I can even make reasonable cases for
going back to the earliest games like
quake where quake was the first really
traumatic game to ship internally where
we're still only talking like two-year
developments but at the time it felt
really long and we had all sorts of
internal strife for things because we
were trying to do so many things it was
you know six degree of freedom rendering
modding I am
internet-based game servers I you know
3/6 off models and it was a lot of stuff
and I later looked back and said you
know we could have done half of those
things in a super doom and shifted
earlier and then done the other half
even better on a game coming in later
and I still roll that over in my mind
sometimes where I love quake and I love
do and I think all of those were doom I
think was the optimal game to ship at
the optimal time quake was challenging
and painful enough that maybe we could
have done some things slightly better
there
[Applause]